that's my intro
[Music]
cursed ikea chair man oh no
we've all been there every single swede
we've all been there oh god that's a
nightmare
who tells people about these things like
who does really embarrassing things and
then tell people
god damn it uh felix trying a diffusion
filter to your lines a cheap way to do
this is literally put a grocery bag over
them here's a comparison of the two same
camera settings my man they already got
it and built in see i know camera look
at good camera you can see my pores you
can see the sweat love it bask in it oh
you want
more blurry wow so cool like
oh i removed it
wow is it a good camera now guys
hey what do you think of these i'm glad
i just finally uh
you know caved in to you guys and got a
good camera thanks for the tip about the
diffusion filter that really helps i got
so tired of the [ __ ] camera memes
like fine i'll buy a [ __ ] decent
camera jesus christ i always thought it
was kind of cool how i did just fine on
youtube without a
a good camera and i'm sure people are
still gonna complain like oh the frame
rate or whatever and it's like yeah i'm
not i'm done no i'm done with the camera
i mean it's not even funny anymore
anyway there's something concerning
about felix spinning a knife near his
neck while talking about silly deaths
[Music]
somehow
they're not real
relax
can i go now guys
please that's actually what happened 100
that's why we have pets just so they can
take photos of us humans in one minute
of plank exercise help dash doom
good point
good point our neighbor always had one
of those
and uh it was especially like low rider
that his balls would always like hang
underneath i always felt bad for him
like it's got to be painful of liv
you know rare photo of felix getting hit
by
yeah it's not it's not a rare occurrence
it happens you're cooking the pasta the
wrong on the way
why would you do this we are testing in
an electrophilic samurai we don't
actually know what's going to happen
that seems like a way to die dumb deaths
[Music]
okay sweet it didn't catch on fire let's
keep going
all right here we go
[Music]
what side i can't hear anything
can they go on an actual kendo
guy to do this or gal so it doesn't look
awkward as [ __ ]
sorry it's that's cool my bad that's
super cool
i want to knock you out but society
won't let me you should buy a freaking
not give me
my nook you mean yeah well some stuff
you it's so important that you have to
say it twice do you understand this just
like you guys keep going and my camera
quality
i got bullied into buying a [ __ ]
camera
beautifying marcia clips i remind you of
how lonely you are oh
that's so sweet
you you're lonely and sad and the teddy
don't worry everyone find love but first
you must love self
but hold you back from love yourself
it's okay save space help oh that's it
oh dude you got stuff back
that's weird some random girls sent me a
fan mail once and now we're back
this is our anime our anime title they
our
light novel anime and re-adaption live
action
how many of us get into red because
appears to be honest uh i am i'm so
sorry that's the case 10 year
anniversary with the best girl this is
so cute love you guys congrats also
random fun fact i just realized you two
met on the exact same day revenge by
kevin sparks came out wow
that's so cool you know in five years i
will be reacting to this and cringing
equally oh [ __ ] this will be a fun
social experiment will you always cringe
from the past what video is it kind of
oh damn
that lighting though holy [ __ ] all right
10 50.
sorry i'm in swedish i i haven't learned
how to do uh youtube yet
he said that he was on top of the
leaderboard how long ago oh
i'm old man he said that he was top of
the leaderboards in zombies and uh i am
pewdiepie welcome to my video you know
in like five years i'm gonna be here
again reacting to this video and
cringing equally what can i say youtube
is a beautiful thing
yeah i guess a little cringe you know
how like i act a little i try to cooler
than i am it's kind of cringe all right
so let's see what i'll cringe at in
another five years
yeah
probably how
i just shaved and i look like a baby i
don't like it it's called progress you
have to cringe at your old self
otherwise you're not improving guys
don't die please
death rate drop zero you're welcome
you're welcome i save lives you're
welcome it's good but he lack a bucket
what is this what's the context whose
setup is that whose setup is that okay i
already saw this and it's so good i
stopped selling hot dogs to play horror
games and guess what i became the most
subscribed youtuber
you gotta watch my anime video with joey
the anime and when to understand the
context but basically we were making fun
of how bad anime titles have gone and
how they literally just described the
plot so i love this is amazing look i'm
also so cute love it cannot love in them
there it is
there it is thing
amazing thank you so much me at the end
of every pewdiepie video hell yeah punch
that baby
i'm merging with the mouse some of the
oh it's me oh it's oh i thought it was
meat canyon but it's the style okay
yours is really good too my bad i just
got excited if you make it father would
you love me forever
of course
jfl creative very epic especially love
what you did with my elbow that's a nice
touch that's some shockable elbows
if i ever saw one this was pewdiepie in
2011. this is him now feel old yet why
do i look the same i got like the same
haircut going hold up
oh my god
[Music]
at least i got these now yeah you're
weak
start lifting you pathetic swede you
know it looks better you know this is my
hair now oh yeah it's the one that
started cussing on twitter about getting
a job at nasa they started cussing out
an actual nasa employee or something
like that and they lost their internship
it's like one of the great tragedies
of the twitter era it's a sad story
laughter
i like this new meme template new meme
template yeah
me buying a new mobile phone to watch
youtube in full screen youtube well now
we're switching it up to 4k quality no
i'm not doing that [ __ ] that we should
be able to handle 1080p now side right
we should be able to do it
the same actors when you google them hey
stop it stop it hell yeah
i gotta end the meme at some point dude
the thumbnails are so bad you don't even
know who i am anymore since you follow
satan you might like pewdiepie wow satan
is my homie
i'm glad he's getting a shout out oh
wait i got a shout out from zayn thanks
sladen when it's 2 a.m and you press
restart and just better
oh well that's when you just plug out
the cable my dude hell yeah looking nice
i don't know if it's too early to tease
but you know we got a lot of requests
for uh you know these things
pewdiepie edition
might come in the future i'm just saying
maybe i bet pewds your cable management
ain't this good dude that is glorious
that's the most beautiful thing i've
ever seen in my life i'm not a thing oh
catch felix dot xc all right let's see
[ __ ]
he's a fast little snake
got him
got him first try got him all right i'll
let you guys play along go ahead and
pause
now
now pause the video
pause the video
come on
we should bring it back
the good old days you guys are some
nostalgic motherfluffas man anime girls
with a surprise face are so cute
oh i saw this family guy called me out
i can't believe it watch this wait who
said that
oh stewie you are just horrible you're
even worse than those people who take
dumps in the shower
[Music]
what's wrong with us tell me
[ __ ] you haven't tried it
we have to do intro hey how's it going
bro my name is pewdiepie welcome to
prague
[Music]
you can't just make up words also
pewdiepie literally is channeled
next time i look at boob i will look at
the book 10 times to compensate some
books i read
care to explain yourself there pewdiepie
joker be like it's a story i love this
meme tumblr
guys enough bowling for poor camera
quality let's appreciate
thank you
holy [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] do you want
from me screw zodiac signs who's your
favorite pewdiepie
rich pewdiepie
boomer pewdiepie he's not going to be
happy about that [ __ ]
normal pewdiepie
chantify pewdiepie cringe that's poking
this uncomfortable streaming santa
yeah that's news right there let's go
another youtuber comments about another
youtuber streamer yeah this happened all
right let's start some news who should i
call them at it's gotta be someone
random random streamer hate it
are you making noises
dumb stream i bet her cable management
terrible hell yeah i like this i'm
saving this
that's beautiful man
oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah this makes sense ken brought
this up as well like the mirror behind
me is kind of messing it up but i think
with the camera i have now they can kind
of handle it enough please for the love
of god i don't care it doesn't matter
that's my whole point like it's like the
whole of internet is trying to make a
big deal out of something that is not
important to you felix can you confirm
this is how you eat pizza yeah
absolutely and it's i'll tell you what
it's the only right way to eat a [ __ ]
pizza why would i waste my tummy space
for and calories on a bunch of gunky
yunky spunky all right listen up if i'm
hungry i'll eat it but i'll eat it last
eat the good stuff first and the bad
stuff last i'm not some child that needs
to prove my mom that i ate my vegetables
so i have to eat the bad stuff first
like an idiot i ate the pizza first
through the middle with an iphone 4. and
anyone that doesn't eat pizza like that
has never tried it i'm sick of it i'm
done with it smash like subscribe on
this video and i see you bros tomorrow
where i will eat a pizza just like that
you thought it was game
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions means our emotions express your
emotions
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this